the next program that we are going to
discuss is for multi-omics for
infectious diseases so here we will
speak about in this program we will
discuss about the emergence and
development of infectious disease
research area and how bioinformatics is
contributing uh contributing uh to this
infectious disease research so we will
actually use again the next generation
sequencing data and how they can be used
and how they can
they can be employed to characterize and
understand the infectious diseases the
pathogens from a data perspective
so yeah
so in this program we will show you
examples of uh how to perform or we will
provide you training on how to perform
sequence variation analysis and
alignment analysis and how to perform
phylogenetic analysis so that you can
understand for example uh how
where you were where your sars variant
or strain
relates to or lie in the lineage of
variance of concern or villages of least
concern
and we will also extend this analysis to
understand the functionality and the 3d
structure of the protein and how a
protein structure can be related to ah
to the to its function and why it is
important in the connotation of um
pathogen in
infection infectious diseases and
pathogens and tree into the post so in
the end you will also get
get the host side of comics data
analysis we can record what the host how
the hosts respond to different
pathogen
pathogenic infection and um from from
understanding the uh transcriptomic
landscape of those response we can get
an idea of
what are the different ways the hosts
are we as a host are trying to
counter-attack the viral outbreak and
virus output
uh with will the multi-omics data
teach us to make hierarchical clustering
based on dna sequence analysis for a
particular genome using yes you can
perform uh clustering using
particular gene or a set of genes
using coding yes that that is included
in in this as well
in this part as well so
yeah okay perfect let me
can you can somebody mute your screen
mute mute yourself i think we have some
disturbances coming up
so okay okay thank you
so we we yeah
so i wanted to talk to you a little bit
more about infectious diseases how how
it is different from non-infectious
diseases and why we are to study uh the
differences between infectious diseases
i will not go over much detail but we
say that infections are caused by agents
that we call as pathogens and these are
usually
virus viroids fungi parasites and
bacteria and non-infectious diseases are
caused by
caused by nutrition deficiency or caused
by chronic development of a different
tectonic response to different factors
like environment lifestyle and it can
also come from genetic inheritance and
uh etc etc so um
we i want to give you uh yeah um
a special overview of how
how uh omics data is actually helping in
understanding the infectious diseases
case so at the same time when we are
developing lot of new techniques to
study these pathogens under microscope
we also have started developing
sequencing technologies so these two
technologies especially in infectious
disease biology complement each other so
um so
the data that we get and the biology
that we study is rich and it has
completely transformed our understanding
of infectious diseases i don't have to
give lot of examples because we are
currently in a pandemic
era and ebola the epidemic that we
encountered in
2014 to 60
excuse me is is one of the first
epidemic to be tracked in real time
using next generation sequencing data so
for for understanding multi-omics
integration in um
in infects is this is biology we don't
have to go far but we can easily take
the ebola pandemic as a case study to
understand how different strains of
ebola are characterized and how
different outbreaks of ebola are
actually
contained
by analyzing the next generation
sequencing data and how we are repeating
the same for
sar score with data all of your variants
of concern and variance of least concern
and double mutant triple mutant of these
variations of these delta and omicron
variants are actually
employing next generation sequencing
data for their characterization so
so as a result as we know that the omics
data is is now regularly used to study
viral genomes it's used to study dna
variations it's used to study
pathogenic gene expression or host g
sorry not pathogenic in explain post
gene expression data and host protein
abundance and the composition of
different
properties of
like microbial community in the meta
genomic center so all of these different
types of data that we have
need to be need to be
effectively analyzed and need to be
mined for different patterns to
understand how hosts respond to the
pathogenic
invasion and how generally pathogen
employs different parts of host protein
machinery to
for its own purpose so
in the end of all these you will you
will be uh you will understand and you
will come develop
a deep understanding in the processing
and analysis methods that are used to
integrate genomic transcriptomic and
meta genomic data so that you can
you can mine
what's in there
we don't have crispr also but if you can
find crispr data that will complement
omix data
nothing stops you from using that sugar
so yeah
we can we give you methods to study
relationship based on for example low
positive for example a
local and multiple sequence comparison
using
using phylogenetic analysis and
pyrogenetic analysis will give you a uh
give you a new world into the
reconstruction of evolutionary
patterns for for example for viruses and
for for different pathogens we also give
you um
different uh for example um
chemical and structural variations that
is observed in the sequence amino acid
sequence that are mapped onto the
protein uh
from for example in the surface protein
of sars on the surface protein of ebola
or in the genes of mycobacterium
tuberculosis and etcetera and we also
give you ways to understand uh the
immunology immune response of the host
by studying their transcriptomics data
uh transcriptomics landscape for a
pathogenic
invasion so with that i can take some
questions that you are uh that you are
busy with or you are
typing with um
and then if you have no further
questions i will pass the stage to dr
mohit who is going to talk to you about
research fellowship